das ist
[Musik]
harte Arbeit
sind Leute
wie du und ich,
ihr wisst, ihr alle habt hier die Schlüssel des
Königreichs, Zeit mit Shi Jing Ping, dem
Oberhaupt von China, dann hat jeder, bevor er
im Oval Office schläft  Ich würde
den Charakter der Nation und meine Ansichten
über die Abstimmung hören und ich meine es wirklich so, dass ich
Dinge mag, die erledigt werden, Dinge erledigt werden, es
gibt mir die Sicherheit für das gute
alte politische Establishment und was für eine
Regierung, die sich für sie einsetzt, wenn
er es ist  Als gewählter Präsident wird er versuchen,
so viel wie möglich zu tun, um diese Dinge zu bekämpfen
und meiner Tochter hier und meinen beiden Söhnen eine bessere Zukunft zu ermöglichen.
Ich denke, seine Energie, seine Ehrlichkeit, seine
Leidenschaft, das sind die Dinge, nach denen ich
suche  Ich glaube, wir kommen da raus
und wir kämpfen als
letzte
[Musik]
hart arbeitende Familie
[Musik] gegen
dich